in Athens the troika received a
less-than-warm welcome as they arrived
to discuss Greece's progress with
painful bailout cuts and reforms in
Brussels representatives of the foreign
lenders were sent to the European
Parliament to defend their methods and
got an equally frosty response the
troika model has proved useful for
dealing with the challenges facing euro
area member states and the three
institutions have stated their
intentions to continue their involvement
in the troika work for the future
economic experts at the hearing called
by emmy pees into the crisis response
we're less than impressed with the
troika's self analysis yet wisdom
dissolution my papas a doll settlement
or seafood affair or particularly cool
austerity it'll appeal a solution it
sounds like propaganda it really sounds
like they're doing some marketing job
and st. justifying the job they've been
doing it is a disaster I mean we wear
every day that passes make the situation
worse and these people are saying well
everything is fine everything okay some
Emmy peas were equally as vocal in their
criticism of the handling of the crisis
which left the eurozone suffering from
its worst recession in the post-war era
an adjustment program that is phased in
destroying employment and is smashing
salaries is actually softly fitting it's
ridiculous are these guys don't
understand that this recipe this austere
aside the recipe is a disaster is
actually killing people and it's
certainly killing the idea of Europe the
Parliament hopes to restore trust in the
EU by reflecting on the successes and
failures of the response to the crisis
however the IMF were noticeably absent
from the debate badal Hadassah at least
Valdez Parliament East reform is the
platform fair transparent so certain not
really fair distance kiss break meet
them international bells for Sue who
Chara's expects to lead an inquiry
report into the troika's work which
should be completed by the time
Europeans head to the polls next year